light on his feet and quick with his job
but Michael Lewis is not like most other
boxers 36 year-old former paratrooper
has an amputated leg and a badly damaged
forearm but he's still beating
non-disabled boxers in white collar
fights most of no beforehand at all
fighting an amputee and if agree to that
in the day you get into that ring you
expected to box and they're there to box
you're there to box and the leg goes you
know disregard it you know you're there
fight in - that's the end of it really
getting here hasn't been easy for
Michael injuries sustained in
Afghanistan led to his leg being
amputated and a series of more than
faulty operations to save his arm
mentally he says his experiences made
him a social kind of grenade that's not
uncommon among injured veterans 70% of
those surveyed by the charity help for
Heroes reported feeling negative after
being medically discharged with his four
fights just weeks away
Malcolm acknowledges that the sport has
helped him out of a dark place
he won his last bout by knockout but
he's not complacent especially when he
has more to think about than other
fighters even if he in different
directions and moving backwards and
forwards and having to think yourself
with the prosthetic is quite hard so
it's okay so having to think and feel
for the movement and when you kind of
feel wider than you are but when you
look down at your feet actually your
feet are in the right place Michael's
fights have already raised more than six
thousand pounds for charity but his
influence goes beyond fundraising I've
said before I get newer students and
they'll say oh I can't do this I can't
do that I've shown my video clip of Mike
skipping off shadowboxing or moving
around and they don't have any more ways
to say basically they go okay and then
they continue trying so he helps me
train other people
[Music]
Michael might not have won every fight
inside the squared circle but in life
he remains undefeated Fraser Maud sky
nice